today I want to talk about the one skill
set that separates the established
business owner that generates income
from his business versus the
self-employed independent contractor who
only makes money off of his own pen
I'm Patrick vivió host of value 10min
weekend today I want to take a look at
the two different sides of entrepreneurs
they're both entrepreneurs but why does
one do so much better than the other one
so think about it we have the
self-employed independent contractor on
one side right
and then we have the established
business owner that has revenues or her
revenues keep getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and it keeps compounding and
you wonder what's the difference between
the two and I will tell you there is one
skill set that separates her from him
one big skill set when you look at the
two it's very simple this person could
even be hardworking incredible in sales
knows the products want very well even
better than this person here but this
person's got one strengths that if he
doesn't pick up it'll be very difficult
for him to compete with this person
running a business and here's what it is
you see a lot of times a safe
self-employed independent contractor
makes a list and saying here's what I'm
good at here's what I'm good at here's
what I'm good at here's what I'm good at
I can do this I'm good in sales now you
know the products that I'm very good at
doing some hard worker on this on this
on that right a lot of times they're
driven by control you know and they
don't believe anybody could do it better
than them and they're normally right but
unfortunately that's also what cost them
from getting to a level of income and
they never get past it you see on this
side the established entrepreneur they
think more like a CEO they already know
what they're good at they don't spend a
lot of time thinking about what they're
good at they're comfortable with that
but they make a list of what they're not
good at and you know what they do after
they make a list of what they're not
good at they go recruit people who are
good in that area and eventually those
weaknesses those are those holes to have
in their business or plot and the
business gets growing and it gets
growing and it gets growing and on one
side this self-employed independent
contractors building a linear income on
this side
the established CEO running it like a
CEO he's building a passive income
growing his business building higher
value for his business with or without
him building equity while this person is
worth their businesses were nothing
without them that's not a valuable
business so my challenge to you is if
you're an entrepreneur you're sort
startup entrepreneur make a list of what
you get out great put it aside but make
a list of what you're not good at and
figure out who you can recruit to make
that strength come out by whoever you
can recruit to do that job well to take
your business to the next level and if
you do that in many cases you'll be
surprised on how fast your business
starts growing to the next level and the
next level and the next level because
the weaknesses are being covered up by
the people you recruited so my message
of the week to you please be sure to
subscribe to this channel if you got any
questions about recruiting be sure to
comment on the bottom today I want to
talk about
ah you needed a blue is that would you
so you're hoping I mess up it's pathetic
my insecurities going to hold different
level every time we do these videos I
walk away from these videos feeling
smaller as a man he recorded that
engineer action it was a pretty intense
action right
I'm Patrick made a video host of I came
in weekly and today I want to talk to
I'm just laughing cause I know he's
about to today I want to talk about
marketing it's a pretty cool socks on I
don't know why they got colorful socks
like this as if I would wear something
like this ever cried to this channel and
comment